so I was just reading over these press
notes yeah and it says that you know yes
it says you have a lego story from when
you were a kid can you tell us that
story yes I will tell you that
embarrassing very embarrassing nerd
story great detail so I was like 10 or
11 and I had created Legos were one of
my favorite toys so I was a big
collector of them and I had many sets
and I had kind of created my own like
basically my own bricksburg in my
bedroom on the floor and I kept getting
told that I needed to clean it up and I
refused and then I tripped over a chunk
of it and the scar and my eyebrow is
from that accident when I was 10 years
old so this experience brought back a
lot of yeah as much as marked mark
exactly but general mayhem the
fantastically named general mayhem
character I'm wondering if when in the
process you saw what the character
looked like and how that sort of
affected what your dad was and I knew
there was a helmet involved from the
beginning very nice so I was always
working on this idea of her voice being
sort of this I took a lot of inspiration
from Darth Vader and from yeah yes Lord
helmet that's me so I always knew that
that was gonna be like the sound that I
wanted to create and then actually
seeing it was Comic Con when I saw the
toy and that was a very sort of strange
moment that I tried to sort of you know
like when you know those moments in your
life where you're like hey wake up right
now I'm like focus on this thing that's
actually happening in your life that was
me in the back of that car looking at
that figurine was like wow when you're
doing a voice work is it sort of like
you just rattle off takes and and hope
that they take the one that you like or
is it or is it sort of depends on the
directions that you're working with but
these directors fill in Chris and Mike
the directors of this film are like
they're very collaborative so they're in
the room with you the whole time
it becomes this sort of back-and-forth
call and responsive play like you try
something you talk about it and try
something else to shout something out I
try something else it's uh it's a really
an exercise in being flexible and using
your imagination you mentioned that you
you took a lot from Darth Vader and
Laura Thielen in the character does sort
of seem like that but it's interesting
that it's it's what a preteen girl would
think of that character I'm wondering if
that if that Pepper it's your
performance at all
you nailed it I'm so glad that you said
that because that's exactly what I was
doing I'm glad you said that because I
was like what if I'm totally wrong
that's exactly what I was doing I mean I
was really interested in this
exploration that the filmmakers are
doing this movie of like when you're
kids especially a preteen girl right
this is I think it's general for all
human beings in that time in your life
but particularly for girls there's a
societal pressure to show up and be
something for other people right to be
almost performative and I think that
this is a really subtle but very
authentic exploration into like what
does a young girl think a superhero is
supposed to look like but at the same
time what is her instinct also telling
her about that character you know about
that part of herself too
[Music]